where is your belief system like what
you believe
like we believe in God
so you believe uh your atheist
I believe there's something out there
I mean only say God firstly God is
a German word okay about when we say God
means do you believe he's a creator that
create this universe
common sense
again
you believe in more than one universe
are you believe in the universe
yeah I mean all of us who believe this
universe exists but Universe cannot
create itself
huh
no that's I'm not trying to no no don't
worry don't worry no no it's okay
we're just we're just talking to you you
come in to do school projects okay
listen no problem I want to have
discussion with you if you want up to
you if you don't want we stop I just get
nervous ah no problem we're okay but
something I want to tell you when you
say universe created itself is a
nonsensical statement because why
if a universe will not existence
therefore it needs something else to
bring it into existence
if I don't know exist I cannot create
myself I don't exist at all so I need
something else to bring me into
existence and that thing cannot be an
object like a camera or something else
just looking at myself you know the
structure of myself we have a nose next
our mouth before we eat smell food we
have eyebrows above our eyes why because
the sweat contains the salt so I can see
there's a wisdom there's a knowledge
there is a power so this attribute that
does not expect itself exists in someone
you understand that's why in the Islamic
teaching Allah mentioned in the Quran
would they create by nothing or do they
create themselves I mean it's impossible
illogical that this universe was created
by nothing or create you create yourself
doesn't make any sense I just can't
personally believe in someone that I'm
not 100 sure even exists because there's
I've never seen him I've never met him
you know and it's kind of hard to
believe something have you met have you
met your great great grandfather
you're great great great grandfather
no no no you're great great grandma
maybe like 400 years ago with a life he
haven't met him okay so this argument of
you have to meet him it's not it's not
conditional to know something exists
with certainty
how do you know
because of the lineage he has lineage
likewise because of this creation when
you reflect upon it it's impossible
is that what the mouth come to you about
your grandfather but the point here is
that when you look at our that's what we
believe in God first is well rooted
within us but sometimes because you're
born in environments that can
divert away from accepting there is God
then we can use the sound reasoning for
example like I said to you let me make
it clear to you you know that's why for
taking your time don't feel pressured
don't worry you know if you want me to
stop I can't stop have you seen the
person who made the phone
we haven't seen it okay
I don't have I don't we don't have to
see the person who made the phone to
know the person who made it must have a
knowledge
must have ability
must have wisdom
type of wisdom Because Why by looking at
the phone I see the structure you know
there's a menu there's a camera all that
organizer so what I have to do just
utilize them as sound reasoning I can
come to conclusion the person who made
the phone must have knowledge power and
ability however I will never be able to
know what is a shoe size because that is
beyond my knowledge beyond the capacity
so this phone isn't a smaller scale what
about you and I what about this universe
when we see everything is connected
everything is organized today is Sunday
tomorrow is Monday how do we know that
but it's sunset in sun rising that's why
in the quranic teaching Allah always
tell us to look and reflect upon Allah's
creation because when you reflect and
you feel you see the order and the
Perfection likewise even on ourselves in
the Quran that we are a clear sign clear
proves for Allah's existence you
understand so also so this is called
universal proof also we have something
called Islamic proof which is the
quranic teaching and I Prophet Muhammad
teaching
that it makes it more stronger why there
is God who's Allah and Islam is the
truth not because I dream it's called
personal experience because I can break
break down for you and show you why
Islam is the truth and why Islam
strengthen our belief give us more
certainty that there is a Creator whose
Allah should be worshiped
I believe in the Creator I believe in
Allah God yeah yeah because when you
don't believe in God it's a big problem
yeah but I feel like people just choose
to be just so they don't know that's
what people have nothing to believe
that you know they're confused you drop
your coffee yeah no no that's one of the
Richard Dawkins statements he tried to
say the reason people believe in God
because they are getting scared of the
environment or the nature that is
incorrect because Prophet Muhammad told
us which I'm going to give you outside
proof but Prophet Muhammad told us that
every child is born to believe in the
Creator
there was a study carried out in Oxford
University that he would do a project
yeah for school so there was a I can't
remember the names now but you can check
it they've done projects sold them three
years and they spent 1.9 million on
these projects they took children from
different parts of the world
children even from background atheist
background they came to conclusion if
you leave children without any prior
education they will grow up believing as
a Creator and there's a purpose in life
so that that rebuke and the bank the
statement the reason people believe in
God because it's kept that's not true
believing God established common sense
it goes in our sound reasoning
it's human nature
two it's human nature no two feet and no
uh the unknown yeah but I'm not saying
that you cannot fear God I mean we wish
Allah based upon fear and love because
we fear everyone is Almighty you know
but I'm not saying I'm not talking about
failing and no no not but what I'm
saying to you there's Universal proofs
and the legislative prove there is a
Creator my question to you if I say to
you imagine you found an iPhone in the
middle of nowhere and I say to you that
phone was made by
Randomness would you accept that be
honest
no it's so organized and programmed what
about this beautiful creation what about
your own creation
that's why Allah said look but you know
what you know people keep asking show me
miracle
yeah your own eyes the miracle
you want to ask for Miracle by your own
eyes it's a miracle our eyes more
complicated more programmed more
organized more connected more
sophisticated than a camera
that cannot come from Randomness or by
chance or blind matter it's impossible
illogical irrational so my question to
you as a smart young girl coming to the
project here which one is make sense
this universe was created by a Creator
who possess the absolute power absolute
knowledge absolute wisdom or by nothing
I mean you talk about unknown feedback
studies from the announcement unseen
from the past I mean Big Bang Theory
some Muslim Church use it to prove
because a big bang is the reaction so
who caused it but I don't even believe
in it I don't believe in Big Bang
everything is made out of science so
everything is made of what science
science is a topic a subjects how is
native science so
no science is like even us we just exist
no science no no science is to study
something science doesn't make something
you know why I'm speaking to you because
you know what's happening you are
repeating something you had in school
because it doesn't make any sense you
know you're telling me it's like I'm
asking you who made the phone you tell
me maps math math is not an entity
that possess power you understand what
I'm saying science is what science is
topic subjects is a is a something that
we we study like study about
universities called science so that's
because cosmology biology sociology and
so on it's called science science is
going to create we create science to
study and understand not science create
us science is a topic it's not entity
what do you call it who made that cup
uh signs of allergy that's the topic you
study in schools
okay what should I say about that
engineering
so what I try to say because I want to
put with a new map
why you feel pressure
now foreign
oh it's not in reality you just uh
if you don't mind asking
systems
like sociology or human rights and stuff
that's what I'm focusing on human rights
okay so I took out freedom of speech
no we don't have freedom of speech
absolutely there's no absence
no there's no absolute freedom of speech
if I stand here and I will say things I
can get arrested there's no absolute
freedom of speech there's not sister
no I can't say
yeah of course like one one of the
prison Africa said he said I will
guarantee your freedom of speech but I
will not guarantee you a freedom after
speech yeah yeah
yeah which is a paradox because if I
have freedom of speech why are you gonna
you want to guide me Freedom after
speech Yes I'm saying because why if we
have we don't have absolute human rights
and like you talk about human rights who
should dictate as human rights is not
human right to not speak would that be
right
dictates
what I'm saying it doesn't mean because
the government dictates something to us
we have to follow them that's what
called Sheep mentality
you know and that's what Islam comes
with that warning against ship mentality
that Allah said bring you proofs we
don't just blindfold because government
the reason I mentioned that I'm not sure
if you're aware with what happened with
Qatar in Qatar
about lgbtq in Muslim countries we don't
accept lgbtq okay and they try to say
that's from the human rights but what
about our human rights
if we start from our human rights to
accept lgbtq the lgbtq that from the
human right to accept them so which
human right should we follow
you see the contradiction
that's why
that's why we need a Creator when the
Creator give us a right it's absolute by
human beings remember we have bias we
have evil desires
you know remember that we have bias and
we have evil desires like I said to one
guy I said if I said to you look I feel
I'm harmless I have no arm I feel like
it literally I feel I was born harmless
even though clearly you see I have an
arm would you help me to cut off my arm
if I said you help me
no so what about people who are saying
they feel they're completely they are a
man but they feel like a woman and we go
and pay money from the taxes money
people are working hard and go change
everything they've been the way they're
created because they feel something else
that's what Allah in the Quran said if
the the truth absolutely should follow
people's desires the heavens and the
Earth be corrupted and we can observe
that right now you know you know we can
see that when we start flowing our
desires there's a man that raped two
women have you heard about it
he was going to the courts
when he was going to the courts for his
sentence
he knew that he's gonna put him in
prison
so what I did and that's apply himself
as a woman and now by law you have to if
you don't accept me you're a bigots you
have to put him in a room in a prison
for him is what is Paradise it's not
prison yeah that's what he's looking for
you see you see the dangerous sister you
seems smart girl you know coming here
are you by yourself coming here to study
and do projects I'll rate you for that
but also I will tell you to learn about
Islam and understand Islam you know
Islam came with five things
and it's five things if we preserve them
we will have a good Society healthy
Society
first one Islam came to preserve
religion what does that mean it means in
Islam if you start worshiping a force
God that including our desires then
we'll have corruption and I will
demonstrate to you that but when you
worship the true God Islam tells you to
protect your intellect that's what Islam
alcohol and drugs is forbidden
thirdly Islam came to preserve wealth
that's why in Islam interests and
gambling is forbidden
fourthly Islam came to preserve marriage
and families that's why adultery and
fornication is forbidden lastly Islam
came to preserve life that's when that's
what harming yourself killing yourself
killing innocent people committing
suicide is forbidden these five things
that Islam came to preserve if we
preserve them we will have a good
Society Alcorn destroyed us individually
and collectively you agree
gambling likewise
yes and what he does to you literally I
know stories no one not sent over 50
stories when you hear people they start
becoming addicts to gambling they go
steal from their children they still
they still PlayStation 2 to go sell it
for our PlayStation 5 I'm back you know
still PlayStation 2 PlayStation 5 and
sell it just to gamble so gambling you
make likewise what they call it interest
is new slavery and just make the rich
Richa poor poorer likewise fornication
adultery destroy societies they have you
have children they don't know their
parents and so on and I grew up the
truth and generally speaking who they
don't know their parents and someone
they grew up mentally not well generally
speaking I understand everyone yes best
exception of that so Islam when he came
to preserve these five things poor
barriers however there is some people
benefit from this devices who are they
the people in power
they do benefit from gambling interest
even though they know it's bad for us so
what they do they because they're rich
they're making money from the south of
the people they use their wealth to make
Islam look bad even though Islam is good
for us individually and collectively and
the question we ask ourselves how men
that existed Prophet Muhammad who came
with Islam how man existed 1 400 years
ago who is able to come which is a
perfect way of life
the five Necessities about protecting
our intellect health and wealth and so
on you know about worshiping the true
God and now
of course I was going to mention to you
because you're talking about the
government and power those who are in
power when Islam comes to preserve these
five things he brought barriers anyone
that break down those those barriers
there's a punishment because we human
beings we don't seek ahead we always
want something quick even though it's
bad for us but the creator of everything
he knows what is good for us in details
what is bad for us in details so when
you look to Islamic legislation and you
compare it to human legislation
Islamic legislation the example I give
is like when you go to a doctor you want
me to go to a doctor and you have a pain
what doctor give you painkillers what
painkillers did do does not treat the
root of the problem painkillers just
manage the symptoms and cover up the
pain but Islamic legislation you okay
yeah all right all right Islamic
legislation deal with a problem from The
Roots
that's why in Islam we have some people
who are even leads to evil you have to
stop it no say yeah I know it leads to
evil but keep doing it like little
alcohol is okay now it's gonna lead to
Greater evil so how Prophet Muhammad is
a perfect way of life he couldn't read
and write but we have these politicians
who studied in the best universities
around the world they cannot raise of
the problems you are facing because
Prophet Muhammad the legislation that he
came with
the legislation of Islam came from the
almighty that's why it's perfect for us
that's what even you agree with it
because it makes sense I understand you
go that's what I'm saying so how men
couldn't read and write he never went to
universities his camera was his perfect
way of life
that strengthened our belief there is a
Creator you know
what do you think what I said so far
about this five universities five things
it makes sense
okay they both have different opinions
about me and stuff and they both want me
to believe two different things yeah and
obviously my sister believes in science
like I was trying to tell earlier yeah
it's just
[Music]
let me tell you something my wife she's
a river to Islam
my wife she becomes 14. she became
Muslim before I met her yes and
mashallah my wife is well versed in
science yes and she became Muslim she
was 14. her mother's atheist
other part of our family Christians yes
her stepfather is atheist okay but
alhamdulillah she was smart enough to
make a decision when she was 14. I don't
know how old you are when she was 14 she
said you know what is that makes sense
to me
I'm gonna follow my mother or my sister
that's what Allah in the Quran always
address the intellects that's when Islam
anything that harms the intellect is
forbidden because that's one of the
tools that we utilize to reflect upon
God's creation likewise upon his
revelation
so think about it look out you know
there's a huge against Islam
no doubt in in Australia in America in
Britain everywhere many articles been
written speaking bad way about Islam in
negative way
but the fastest growing religion on the
face of the Earth especially in the
Western World in Europe and America is
Islam even though there's many barriers
by those who are in power they have
stronger tools to stop stop Islam but
they cannot stop it because Allah told
us Allah will make Islam spread out even
if a disbeliever dislike it and Allah
mentioned that 1 400 years ago that's a
prophecy that we can observe with our
own eyes
you know that's why you know people say
Islam in Britain America you know
probably accepted Islam so I understand
you're saying about your family about
science you know yes you study about the
universe
sometimes science is being used to
manipulate us
sometimes they tell you are you aware of
that
There Is A Commentary I will tell you to
watch
call The Expelled ones
Abbas how many
it was done by a Jewish journalist uh I
would tell you which one so please I'll
advise you to try to watch it why expose
how many universities when they see
science believe in God they will start
harassing them
and they always try to push scientists
who does not believe in God so clearly
there's agenda I will show you this one
yeah and I really appreciate your time
you know
I'll show you around
there's a commentary yeah about how
they're experience so it says expelled
once no intelligence allowed it's a
Jewish journalist he's famous I forgot
his name you know and he goes to the top
Universe in America and he speaks to
some scientists who were sacked from
their jobs even they're good at it
because in the articles that are
speaking about this universe indicate
there's a Creator that's the harassing
them so talking about freedom I agree we
have to give freedom but there is
restriction no doubt about that because
giving absolute freedom will make chaos
you know so he starts exposing them that
you claim that you follow signs and
approves but when you have a scientist
who are qualified and experts in their
fields you are rejecting them as for my
channel
that's my channel
[Music]
yeah of course
also we have Instagram so if you have
Instagram this is our Instagram page
okay do you have any questions
but I think about it you know think
because when they were going to die they
were going to live this life have you
been to Algeria
have you been Morocco never imagine
you're gonna travel tomorrow coach
Algeria what you have to do first before
traveling you have to study which
currency they use
it's a safe country it's a cold country
okay what language they speak so
likewise you have to understand why we
have to die where's my purpose every
party every part of your body has a
purpose you know what is my purpose ask
questions and I believe this question be
answered in the holy book of the Muslim
the Quran I mean I don't have the Quran
otherwise I'll give it to you but if you
can send us a message via our Instagram
I can send you a PDF to read
okay thank you very much for listening
I'm sorry if I said something rude to
you or something yeah sure I'll take you
yourself yeah all right